[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video i want to discuss my
feelings regarding the possibility
of some new harry potter content some
news came out in february
that basically suggested that hbo is
currently developing
or planning to develop a harry potter tv
show
no other information was released and
apparently no writers or talent are tied
to the show
yet but it's looking like it's going to
happen
and honestly why wouldn't it the harry
potter franchise is one of the most
popular in the world
why wouldn't they give fans what they
want it's not guaranteed but i've
certainly got my hopes up
and what i want to discuss in today's
video are my predictions for what the
show will be about
obviously with such an in-depth universe
and so many different characters
timelines there are tons of
possibilities but i think i've managed
to narrow down
the biggest ones sit back relax and
enjoy the video
when the last book was released there
was certainly a sense of finality when
it came to the harry potter series
however fortunately the films were
lagging behind which meant that they
were able to keep the same magic alive
for a few more years however when the
deathly hallows finally ended
i didn't really know what to watch next
so i did what any other sane harry
potter fan would do
i started the films and books again from
the beginning we're now in 2021 which
means that it's been 14 years since the
last book came out
and 10 years since the last movie came
out which effectively means that i've
now repeated this re-reading
re-watching process more time than i
care to admit with fans longing for more
magical harry potter-related content
jk rowling and warner brothers answered
with fantastic beasts somewhere to find
them
which came out in 2016. the film had
varying reviews
and though it was a far cry from the
harry potter films that i so knew and
loved
i appreciated the effort i thought it
was an okay movie certainly not
comparable to the franchise from which
it was based
but did a decent job as far as a prequel
goes then
just two short years later fantastic
beasts the crimes of grindelwald was
released
in 2018. this film in my opinion did a
better job of tying in the magical world
that we already knew and loved
i think that the fan reception of the
first film was clear give us more of
what we know
and love we want new but maybe not
everything
what this meant for the film was more
connections to the harry potter world in
the form of characters
places creatures and references we even
got to see dumbledore
unfortunately it's now november 2020 and
i say unfortunately because november
is when fantastic beasts 3 was
originally supposed to be released
however it has clearly not been released
in fact we're now looking
at a summer 2022 release date this is
for a number of reasons
a total screenplay rewrite which is a
plus covered delays
and now the recasting of the primary
antagonist johnny depp
kellet grindelwald with that said many
fans are upset with the way that the
harry potter franchise has been handled
i'm happy with fantastic beasts and i'm
really interested to see where they go
with it
now that more time and effort has been
allocated toward the film
however one thing that i've always
thought is that rather than making
prequels to the harry potter films and
follow entirely different characters
why couldn't warner brothers have
pursued something that was different but
still familiar i am of course talking
about spin-offs that follow origin
stories of characters that we know and
love
spin-offs that discuss how the wizarding
world that we know came to be the way
that it is
fantastic beasts sort of does this but
still feels like it's independent from
the harry potter films in a lot of ways
here are some of the things that i'd
like to see first of all an origin story
for the marauders
the marauders were a group of
mischievous young boys who attended
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
during the 1970s these four boys were
characters that you've probably heard of
james potter sirius black remus lupin
and peter pettigrew
the quartet of boys began their studies
in 1971 the same year as severus snape
and they all had one thing in common
they were all gryffindors before the
sorting ceremony even happened
the boys hit it off and when they were
eventually sorted into the same house
they knew that they were destined to be
friends though the boys got on one to
many of their other classmates
this particular group of four boys had a
truly special bond
and they eventually came up with a name
for their group they were the marauders
the boys had a lot in common beyond the
fact that all of them were gryffindors
as they all also happened to be huge
troublemakers
if there was a rule at hogwarts they
were hell-bent on breaking it and they
were truly notorious for their rule
breaking
and mischief making their group existed
for the duration of the time that they
spent at hogwarts from 1971
to 1978 and after graduating they even
all went on to join the order of the
phoenix
a secret society founded by dumbledore
that opposed lord voldemort
this is a group of four characters that
are integral to the harry potter story
that already have a pre-established
backstory that could easily be adapted
into an independent narrative
james is the father of the boy who lived
serious black is the man who lost his
friends
and basically his entire life in one
fateful night lupin is the boy who was
bitten by the notorious werewolf fenway
greyback
and pettigrew is the sniveling excuse
for a man that went down a very dark
path
these are four massive characters and i
think that i certainly speak for other
fans as well when i say
make the show the next spin-off that i'd
like to see
involves the four hogwarts founders and
the founding of the school itself
hogwarts goes with harry potter like
marmite goes for toast they're meant to
be
so in my eyes it only makes sense to
provide an origin story that explains
how the school
came to be the founders are such
enigmatic figures powerful wizards
thought to be more powerful
than modern day wizards and i want to
see that on the big screen
or at the very least the small screen in
my house
hogwarts was founded at some point
during the 10th century it was built
hidden off somewhere in the scottish
highlands
the exact location is never actually
revealed and this was because the 10th
century was a time of hardship for
witches and wizards
during this time every day witches and
wizards were being persecuted by muggles
who were intensely hostile when it came
to witnessing sources of magic
this was a different time a time very
much unlike what we're used to seeing
in the magical world hogwarts was
founded when four 10th century witches
and wizards got together
and decided that they had in the sorting
hat's own words the self-serve yearning
to make the world's best magic school
these founders were godric gryffindor
rowena ravenclaw
salazarin and helga hufflepuff thus
hogwarts was born not only was this a
time when the school was created but it
was also when the house system was
introduced
gryffindor slytherin ravenclaw
hufflepuff have you heard of them
wouldn't you like to know what the first
students of the houses were like what
the og of the respective house was like
well make the show the next spin-off
that i want to see made involves none
other than lord voldemort
voldemort intrigues me what an
interesting character and when we see
glimpses of his past
and him at varying stages of his life
i'm only left even more intrigued
now there's a possibility that voldemort
will appear in fantastic beasts
and this could be a very smart move on
warner brothers part if
it's executed well however if he doesn't
show up i still want to see a voldemort
origin story
we know that voldemort turns into a
murderous dark wizard intent on
dominating the wizarding world
and achieving blood purity but what i
want to see are the steps in his
childhood that got him to that point
i want to see him at wall's orphanage
and witness how he interacted with the
other children
i also want to see him at hogwarts
making friends with the original death
eaters
i want to see him grow up a voldemort
origin story could be a great way of
going back into wizarding history
and doing a character analysis in the
primary antagonist of the harry potter
films
so i'll say it again make the show
another spin-off that i want to see made
involves albus dumbledore
albus was a magical prodigy he was able
to do things with a wand that no one had
seen before
and given that we're only shown the old
age dumbledore i really wanted to see
what he was like as a boy
again the fantastic beast films may
touch on this but i'm not sure how much
and how far back they'll go the premise
of fantastic beasts surrounds the defeat
of gelat grindelwald
who plays quite a large role in
dumbledore's story but what i want to
see
is dumbledore's father being sent to
azkaban and dumbledore's sister being
killed
after being caught in the crossfire of a
three-way jewel involving aberforth
albus and grindelwald i want to see all
of this on screen and the subject matter
is certainly there
so i'll say it one last time make the
show
that's it for today's video i hope you
enjoyed something a little bit different
what spin-offs do you want to see made
if you agree with the ones i mentioned
above
then share the video and get the word
out there do any of these appeal to you
more than the others
leave a comment down below until next
time there is plenty to be learned
even from a bad teacher what not to do
how not to be